this video is sponsored by skillshare i
just got through reading this book right
here viral sensation a little life by
hanya yanagihara it's also the book that
you'll often see in thumbnails like this
or this these are youtubers i really
love i've been reading for the past two
days it feels like i've been doing
nothing but reading almost halfway
through
i'm ready for it to be over it seems
like it took on a new life in 2020 in a
kind of lens of letting people
view you at your saddest now i know what
you're thinking you want to see this
mask of ironic detachment dissolve
you want to see me cry
and i love
these videos don't get me wrong i think
they're really entertaining after the
tears have fallen after the shock and
sadness has set in after reading this
book that there is reflection there is a
sense of what what just happened was it
authentic did i feel cheated
[Music]
but before this awards from our sponsor
skillshare
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
classes for creators explore new skills
deepen existing passions and get lost in
creativity with
skillshare i've been using skillshare
for a while now they've been a really
reliable and fantastic sponsor for the
channel and though i've tried out a lot
of different courses i'll say it again
that one of my favorite and most useful
courses i've found is the writer's
toolkit six steps to a successful
writing habit by simon van boy it just
covers the real practical
uh and useful elements of setting up a
writing routine if you want to be a
writer you can't really be a writer
without having a consistent routine and
cranking out those words and that's just
the that's the reality of it the
unavoidable reality you can view it in
bite size videos or watch the full
course it's curated specifically for
learning meaning there are no ads
skillshare now offers classes in spanish
french portuguese and german the first
thousand people click on the link in the
description get skillshare for free for
one month that's that's free i mean i
mean it's it's free if you click just
click on anyways check it out learn
something new thank you to skillshare
for sponsoring this video now back to it
so why are people obsessed with this
dang book why do people want to
subject themselves to this especially
young people online let's talk about the
most basic reason that's fomo the fear
of
making uh omelets the fear of missing
out i guess there's a kind of snowball
effect and you don't really want to miss
out once everyone else is talking about
it you need to see well what's it all
about second let's talk about the time
period when this novel became really
popular online came about in 2020 2021 a
lot of people are stuck in their houses
because there's a little thing going
around
i remember at the time and a lot of
people talked about this how it felt
like uh time had both stopped and was
just speeding up people who are very
young people who are in college in high
school they're missing out on very huge
life experiences you know they're not
able to go to their graduation i think
what maybe appeals to this kind of
headspace of being isolated being stuck
inside of feeling like the world is
passing you by like life is passing you
by is reading a book that is like
compressing the entire existence of
several people into 800 pages i get why
people become obsessed with this book
and find it uh beautiful you can even
chart in my own vlogging of when the
spell started to fade it's like watching
a car crash in slow motion like you have
you can't pull your eyes away but you
have to see what happens next and it's
just kind of like a testament to okay
how far can we can we punish the the
readers there there's a kind of
catharsis that comes from pain from
wallowing in despair so let's talk about
catharsis what i mean by catharsis is
that a kind of emotional release a deep
sense of letting it all out a lot of
people when they try to get this book
they go in knowing and aware this is
going to make them cry this is going to
be emotionally heavy it's going to rip
them apart they want that honestly when
i was getting into it so was i i was
thinking you know what i could use a
little cry but once you get into it
there became a sense of voyeurism a
weird feeling like i'm getting some kind
of sick pleasure because catharsis i
think there's pleasure in that i was
getting sick pleasure from feeling
miserable
about this person's life and how
they personally are on are not able to
overcome the the trauma they have
endured we are watching from the outside
in
of a character who is going through
things that are very serious very
difficult you know
the most difficult topics you can
discuss it's shown in intense
excruciating detail the events and
actions but the aftermath this book in
particular can be kind of harmful it
becomes problematic when you
read the author's words about the book
as for the limits of therapy i can't
speak to them only that therapy like any
medical treatment is finite in its
ability to save and correct i think of
psychology the way i think of religion a
school of belief or thought that offers
many many people solace and answers an
invent an invention that defines the way
we view our fellow man and how we create
social infrastructure one that has
inspired some of our greatest works of
art and philosophy but i don't believe
in it talk therapy i should specify
myself one of the things that makes me
most suspicious about the field is its
insistence that life is always the
answer every other medical specialty
devoted to the care of the seriously ill
recognizes that at some point the
doctor's job is to help the patient die
that there are points at which death is
preferable to life that doesn't mean
every doctor will help you get there of
course but almost every doctor of the
critically sick understands the
patient's right to refuse treatment to
choose death over life but psychology
and psychiatry insists that life is the
meaning of life so to speak that if one
can't be repaired one can at least find
a way to stay alive to keep growing
older when i read these comments after
reading the book it all it all came
together in a lot of ways and it kind of
felt like we were being given a lecture
and there is this kind of malicious
intent by an author to say that
sometimes you need to give up
in the most extreme way it's you you
need to die
like it's really bleak really bothers me
um look i'm not trying to argue that
therapy is the answer for everything is
it okay to make a story that just
relentlessly punishes your reader and
will there come a point when that reader
starts to rebel against the author i
could i could
see reading this book and coming away
with a very very harmful message really
harm people if they're not going in into
it um
aware of what they're gonna get now
yanagihara has some very strong opinions
about trigger warnings ones i don't
necessarily agree with i don't think
books necessarily have to have a
redeeming quality or a message perfectly
fine for a book to show the bleakness to
show their despair for a while that's
what this book was doing wonderfully and
i thought wow you know it's it's it's
sad but it's beautiful it's it's honest
but there comes a point when the
melodrama starts to come in reality
leaves
and you start to see the author taking
on the role of god and you start to get
angry at the author because there are
those who will say the point of the book
is to bring in this melodrama and this
hyper realism and mix them together and
it makes something new that's
interesting in theory i thought that it
was not handled very well i thought it
was actually handled kind of
irresponsibly to be perfectly honest i
don't know like i don't i don't want to
say books have to be responsible or have
to have to have this moral
value or whatever but when yana gahara
says that she did no research into this
type of childhood abuse makes me kind of
sad from what i've read about other from
other people who are more knowledgeable
about these subjects that yanagihara
does a poor job of depicting this i
think the novel is good at exploring the
repetitiveness of depression of how
there's not one linear way to recover so
in the end why is the internet obsessed
with a little life it's a long book and
it's kind of more fun to just watch
someone else cry i don't really want to
be reading this 800 page book about the
worst things in life and cry all day
about it but it's fun to watch someone
else do it
so beautiful maybe i'm a cold-hearted
son of a [ __ ] and yeah thanks for
watching from here on out spoilers
what the [ __ ] you know i really enjoyed
the descriptions of these characters of
their lives i thought like oh i'm gonna
have fun jumping between these four
characters and then it becomes just
about jude and as much as jude is very
interesting he's not a dynamic character
which is the point i get it but it
becomes so repetitive so so repetitive
hard to criticize this book for being
repetitive when that's the point there's
there was a point where
it just becomes so unrealistic and over
the top that you can't help but question
the author's motivations i think jude
was responding realistically to these
situations i had to get angry at the
author for putting him through these
situations just for my own just to crush
me up and it becomes a parody of itself
almost like this is excessive like this
is too much this book should have been
cut down but also it couldn't have been
because the length kind of justifies
needlessly over the top
narrative i was kind of going with it i
was like i can do this i can accept it
because the characters are feel so lived
in by the time i got to the end of the
happy years i
and you guys who have read it will know
um why that at the end of the happy
years william dies in a car crash right
and i remember reading like right before
i was like okay because as they were
driving i was just like okay
everything's really happy wouldn't it be
funny if willem just gets in a car crash
like that seems like that would be what
would just make things so horrible
literally the next page he gets in a car
crash and dies and i was like really but
when it happened i felt
just dead inside i was like no that's
enough like that's the author becoming
the hand of god just you know sticking
her hand into the story and saying yeah
[ __ ] you first off just like a car crash
like i get that that happens but it also
it's like to me that's the most random
flippant thing you could put in to just
like [ __ ] with your characters by that
time i was like jude has been through so
much [ __ ] and it's like i we've i've
been with him i've gone through all of
the times he's been hurt and recovered
and tried to heal and and then to just
throw this in there like
just to prove a point that like like
jude is just like needs to give up i
don't know just like why why
it just annoyed the hell out of me and
that's when the character started
feeling fake willem was just like this
saint build up to just be killed in a
car accident although he wasn't that
much of a saint you know the way he
treated jude a lot of ways at first i
liked the the lack of period details how
it feels like it could exist at any time
in the modern age
um i thought it was like okay we're just
going to focus on their internal lives
and stuff but it also
in a way just kind of reflected the
insularity and isolation of so wealthy
and privileged that you don't have to
worry about the community about the
outside world you know it just they
there's so much emphasis from jude's own
language from howie's
description of his body you know that he
is so irreparably broken bad cliches
about being disabled i think it makes
sense that yanagihara did not do any
research about jude
jude growing up and about child abuse
and about being disabled i think that it
shows and i think that when you you
should seek out uh reviews from people
who are disabled who have experienced
these things who can tell you that it's
not terribly
accurate hoping to see more also from
the
uh characters malcolm and jb they just
kind of left part way through the book
like just midway through the book
they're just gone and they just become
like these cut out characters like i
wanted to know about their lives about
who they became but no we're just
repeating the same stuff about jude over
and over and i think that's where the
story just fundamentally breaks and how
it lost my attention that by the end of
the book it feels like what else
do we have here you know the point is
just that we suffer jude's friends
aren't necessarily good friends because
well some of them do look out for him
and by the end of the book you know they
have an intervention with him you know
in his 50s his friends really weren't
looking out for him earlier in the book
they were enabling him i don't think
that's really what friends should do it
just failed on so many levels i was
really disappointed with the character
of willem that i mean i think that
yanagihara can write great scenes and
the characters feel alive in that scene
but then as the story moves on it's like
they just become
whoever they need to be for the purposes
of jude's suffering in one scene jb
feels alive and lived in in the next
scene he feels like he's just there to
punish jude it's just amazing how it
could capture me so perfectly for half
of this book that by the end of it i was
feeling nothing and i was actively angry
at it like it's just amazing how there
could be that 180. the book is effective
you know
i feel tired of talking about this book
i'm ready to read something different
thank you for watching
i hope you have a great day
alright
bye bye
you